breaking news this lunch time children
who claim that they were being abused by
the former labour peer lord janna were
let down by institutional failings a
report from the independent inquiry into
child sex abuse said children in the
care of leicestershire county council
were not given the attention they
deserved
our correspondent
is in central london for us ali just
remind us a little bit about the
background to this and what this report
hasn't revealed
yes jane this is a report 75 pages long
it's been long awaited and as you say it
finds that children have been let down
by institutional failings i think it's
worth reminding people that this report
was never about deciding whether or not
lord janna is innocent or guilty it was
about looking at how institutions the
crown prosecution service the police the
labour party leicestershire county
council dealt with those allegations of
sexual abuse whether he received
preferential treatment because of his
position of power and this report looked
at a number of different police
inquiries first operation magnolia which
was an inquiry that started in 2000 and
it found that there was a deliberate
decision made by police to withhold key
witness statements from the crown
prosecution service and it says that
that was serious and inexcusable and
crucially it says that children in care
were distrusted and then it looks at a
second operation a few years later in
2006 again it says the officers were
reluctant to push the investigation
forwards but importantly though it does
not say that that was because lord jana
was given preferential treatment because
of his political position and to remind
you as you asked about the background
lord janna died facing 22 allegations 22
charges against nine boys he's accused
of assaulting
boys in leicestershire county care homes
where he was the mp he always denied
those allegations his family continued
to say that he has been denied his day
of call in court because of course he
died
being deemed by judges unfit to stand a
criminal trial but today this report
finds that leicestershire county council
has a sorry record of failure in
relation to its children in care
leicestershire county council were
saying told the inquiry that they accept
that steps should have been taken to
stop those failures from happening and i
think it's also worth reminding people
that this is one of a number of reports
as part of the independent inquiry into
child sex abuse it's looked at a number
of different institutions including
councils there was a report into lambeth
council for example religious
groups these inquiries do not actually
have the power to enact change that will
be down to the government